[Music]
so you're a pop culture fanatic Game of
Thrones the biggest thing in pop culture
right now are you into it not into it
real I know I know you're not supposed
to not like Game of Thrones I like it
but you know Conan I only watch it for
the titties I love titties yeah I loved
all those titties on Game of Thrones so
much that's always been your weakness
always your Achilles heel I just I can't
get enough of those those fine titties
just the way you speak about it three of
them right now how much I love those
titties I shoot a foot in the water
uh-huh so anyway so you're not you're
not you don't love Game of Thrones but
you like seeing you the nudity you like
the nudity yeah except I'm more of a
sitcom guy so I want to you know see all
those titties hanging out on Hot in
Cleveland that would be my preference
you want to see Hot in Cleveland nudity
want to see Perry Gilpin's titties go
okay well I'm sure we can make sure
she's on Hot in Cleveland and she played
Roz on Frasier huh
now you've been tweeting lately that
Anne Hathaway about Anne Hathway I tweet
a lot about Anne Hathaway and and that
she you say she makes you crazy now I
find her to be quite lovely what's your
problem with Anne Hathaway well the
thing she's a very good actress and
she's very pretty I like watching a
movie she just you know she's a little
precious she doesn't have a ton of self
awareness and that drives me crazy so
sometimes I have fun with her on Twitter
like Anne Hathaway's the type of person
who goes out in the middle of a storm
and tells everyone that she's decided to
embrace the rain you know there was an
earthquake recently in LA I recently
moved here and it was my first
earthquake and I just everyone was
tweeting about it and I decided to tweet
as if I was Anne Hathaway reacting to
the earthquake right and she lives in
New York so I tweeted I'm not in LA but
I felt the earthquake in my own way
[Laughter]
Billy on the street
you're in your third season now you're
having terrific celebrities yeah I mean
great people Amy Poehler best we saw
Paul Rudd Lena Dunham and absolutely
terrific we have a clip here who's her
special guest on I think this is me
talking to Patton Oswalt hilarious whoo
I love love love brilliant Patton Oswalt
and he did the voice of the rat and
ratatouille
yeah Pixar movie which is my favorite
Pixar movie and it's always made me a
little angry that that movies a little
bit more underappreciated than the other
Pixar movies and here's what I had to
say about it because I went to
Disneyland I saw there was no
ratatouille ride and I got very upset
alright let's check out this clip from
Billy on the street I went to Disneyland
this is the truth I went to Disneyland
recently there's a whole land devoted to
that stupid piece of Cars movie
one piece of evidence that ratatouille
ever existed yeah there's no it's hard
to do a ratatouille ride tell me there's
a food court I've read pictures of rats
making pizza you're right
unbelievable I paid $100 to get in there
and then they don't have the decency to
offer me some type of ride where I can
sit on some sort of phenomenal rack
[Applause]
thank you I have to correct myself and
II just corrected me Peri Gilpin Roz on
Frasier is not on Hot in Cleveland
that's Jane Leeves yes that's Jane
Leeves oh right I was right all
stretched in my life I know but I still
I still want to see Perry Gilpin's
titties well I'm glad everyone's happy
yeah I'm glad we straightened that out
thanks a lot Andy